the conflict boosted gas prices here in
the u.s to an all-time high overnight
the national average is now four dollars
and 17 cents a gallon the biden
administration is still considering
options to try to ease some of the pain
at the pump we should zhang is at the
white house was more on that part of the
story we said the prices are going up
and people here are not happy but i hear
people are willing to pay if it's going
to help the people in ukraine good
morning to you
good morning to you gail good morning
everybody that's exactly why congress is
still preparing to pass bipartisan
legislation to stop buying russian oil
because lawmakers say they don't want
any american dollars funding the war and
president biden has vowed to do whatever
he can along the way to bring gas prices
down but it is who he is turning to
instead of russia that is raising some
new questions
on a video call president biden and
european allies promise to keep
punishing russia possibly with a ban on
buying its oil a new national poll shows
the majority of americans 71 percent
said they would support the move even if
it meant higher gas prices here in the
u.s
no decision has been made at this point
speculation alone caused stocks to
tumble monday on wall street marking the
worst day of the year for the dow and s
p 500 while prices at the pump soared
hitting a 14-year average high of more
than four dollars is there any way to
gauge how much pain people should brace
themselves for i do think that there is
a path to potentially seeing you know
five dollar a gallon
russian oil only makes up about three
percent of u.s oil imports but halima
croft a commodity strategist warns if
other western countries also cut off
moscow
the shortage would drive up costs
everywhere
croft says even though the white house
is talking to iran and venezuela about
making up the difference only one source
can offer an instant solution saudi
arabia
and the question is is president biden
willing to place the phone call to the
saudi crown prince this is all
a means of exposing the insanity of u.s
energy policy that forces us to
negotiate between one brutal dictator
and another brutal dictator
the white house is pushing back against
reports that president biden plans to
travel to saudi arabia to talk about oil
saying there are no such plans right now
as for russian oil some european leaders
have already said that's not realistic
for them to stop buying it because the
economic consequences would be so dire
if the u.s implements an embargo alone
experts say that would have more of a
symbolic than a financial impact nate
we'll have to wait and see ouija thank
you